à polytechnique montréal il y à bien des
hommes à cette journée portes ouvertes
76 % des étudiants sont des hommes
technique on performe quand même bien
par contre de plus en plus de femmes
veulent devenir ingénieur c'est pas
parce que c'est un domaine plus masculin
que je crois capable donc je continue à
pousser puis je tends je suis en 4e
année gymkhana encore sabrina watts elle
fait partie d'une équipe d'étudiants en
génie qui participent à des concours
internationaux
ils doivent construire et faire voler un
petit appareil capable de transporter la
plus grande charge possible
l'an dernier l'équipe est allé au texas
première et c'est la catastrophe devrait
aller qu'on a pu constater qu'il y avait
vraiment une différence entre est ce
qu'on apprend encore la théorie et la
pratique
l'équipe travaille d'arrache-pied et
modifie les ailes de l'avion pour la
deuxième journée de compétition
bravo il décolle magog
mais catastrophe plus grave encore
on attend en les disant que les avions
ne sont pas encore inventé en 1873 quand
l'école polytechnique et créer
l'institution grandi avec des sommes que
des hommes
les années passent il n'y a encore que
des hommes regardez la promotion de 1962
63 des hommes des hommes des hommes et
l'a finalement michel thibodeau une
première femme diplômé en génie civil et
celle là c'est moi cinquante et un ans
plus tard je suis michèle thibodeau
deguire et je suis maintenant présidente
de polytechnique le pire au meilleur
la présidente il ya verriers pour pour
attirer les filles c'était vraiment où
on ouvrait les portes et moi c'est mon
père il m'a dit écoute votant un génie
tu vas adorer ça j'ai cru membres y
avait raison
aujourd'hui les femmes représentent 24 %
des étudiants de polytechnique montréal
et pourtant les femmes sont aujourd'hui
majoritaires dans presque toutes les
facultés à l'université de montréal
endroit elles sont 65% en médecine 75%
aux primaires pourtant garçons et filles
sont égaux et chacun a les rêves de son
âge
toi tu voudras est acté et toi ah bon et
toi c'est pour les garçons et ça
n'empêche c'est pour les garçons et pour
les faits c'est une 6 et pourquoi pas le
gène ikke plutôt que la garderie le
matin le sens horaire autres arts il
contrôlait parfois c'est ici qu'entre en
jeu folie technique des étudiants de
polytechnique se rendent dans des
classes du primaire et mène avec les
élèves des expériences techniques dans
cette classe on construira en quelques
semaines des robots téléguidés fait de
blocs lego essayer ça les jeunes filles
sont particulièrement visés par folie
technique
il ya beaucoup de préjugés par rapport
aux faits aux sciences ont regardé les
gosses et souvent les petits garçons qui
vont utiliser les lego quand son petit
donc des choses comme ça ça leur permet
vraiment de
deux touchés pizza mais finalement ça
veut dire je suis capable de le faire de
le réaliser
si elles s'intéressent aux sciences dès
le primaire les jeunes filles pourraient
continuer au secondaire puis au cégep et
qui sait cégépienne elles viendront
s'informer à la journée portes ouvertes
de polytechnique montréal prête à
plonger dans ce monde d'hommes ces défis
à relever mais s'il se démarquer en tant
que femme dans les domaines font
traditionnellement réservé aux hommes
je me souhaite pionnière goût ouais bah
j'aime cette diriger si je peux diriger
des hommes 30 avenue 24 % de femmes en
génie est ce que ça vous satisfait non
non je suis sûr qu'il ya plus que 25% de
femmes qui auraient ses aptitudes à
faire des études en génie qu'est ce qui
chez laurent qu'est ce qui les bloquent
mais je dirais qu est-ce qui les bloque
je vois regarder tout le chemin on a
fait
michel thibodeau était bien seul à
l'époque aujourd'hui quoique
minoritaires les femmes sont quand même
des centaines a étudié le génie à
polytechnique montréal des femmes comme
sabrina wattel qui deux semaines
seulement après l'écrasement de l'avion
de son équipe était de retour en
compétition internationale avec un
nouvel appareil qu'ils ont redessiné et
reconstruit on ne pas donner un bon
nous sommes engagés non on ne peut pas
l'avion a fait son tour de piste et
s'est posé doucement à wollega avons les
filles